الى ملف اخر فقد وقعت تركيا والامارات
العربيه المتحده اتفاقيه شراكه اقتصاديه
شامله سيتم بموجبها الغاء الرسوم
الجمركيه او الغائها عن ثلاثه وتسعين في
المئه من المبادلات التجاريه غير النفطيه
بين البلدين وبذلك تصل قيمتها الى اربعين
مليار دولار خلال سنوات الخمس المقبله
وقال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في
اتصال بالرئيس الاماراتي الشيخ محمد بن
زايد ان الاتفاقيه ستعزز صداقه وتعاون
الثنائي وشكر دوله الامارات على دعمها
لبلاده بعد زلزال السادس من فبراير الماضي
من جانبه قال رئيس دوله الامارات
الاتفاقيه الشراكه الاقتصاديه الشامله مع
تركيا خطوه نوعيه في مسيره علاقات البلدين
وانها ستعزز التعاون الاقتصادي والتجاري